[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certaines sommes
du
bienvenue on va tomber sur le site de
bruxelles
située en seine c'est un espace protégé
depuis 1980
et le département il est soigné depuis
[Musique]
le site auprès d'autres outils sexy de
environ ce qui sépare de la plage à la 4
fois et de la mer or ici
[Musique]
c'est ce site a planté des salaires et
les musiciennes l'époque que pour
trouver ici
et
bodmer le brochet
filao
enfin y'a que l'espèce est aux ti cats
et les oiseaux
au final
on peut trouver aussi de temps en temps
bobigny seine saint denis jeunet mic
[Musique]
bon après tout c'est le site le matin
vers 6h ont à s'excuser en était
5h30 commencer conclut le fond le maire
votre
probable son compte en banque le tout en
haut en bas ça passe en retrait pour
premier ensuite un passé en la personne
du stockage
[Musique]
des plantations et de l'argile dans les
big three inquiétez
pour monter en intensité
cette fonction du vent
ont fait leur arrivée dans la nourrice
avait montré que ça le soit il ya quatre
autres italiens
on aura la fin de celle de ses premiers
la place formée en surface on ctpa
désolation ramasse pas tomber au fond du
bassin lors du gros sel il serait encore
plus longtemps quand lé bassin on
obtient du seul kilo cette finance et du
pivot christophe donc on peut tracer
ensuite c'est celle là ça n'a pas pu
ramasser il ya trop de vent va partir
pour les piscines d'après les détails
en général tous les sites
départ 6
voyager lagarde plutôt
content et quand un mauvais niveau du
bassin
[Musique]
emporte le maire répond fait paraître un
band et jour un vieux un mois ballot ça
monte un an peut-être ça l'était moins
au départ on de gamme et 150 g
c'est pas la subir nationale ont procédé
dans un liquide dedans
staline dans l'est
la nourrice
la nourrice le déjà en selle selles
liquides
que ça tu vois
pas trois jours après on va retenir
[Musique]
on
ne voulait pas les voir entre le bassin
il évoque bien sûr oublier
celle amenée dans la vallée c'est la
bonnotte deux jours ça m'a ramené la
forme sauvage
pendant cinq six mois bien écoutez bien
les deux le
[Musique]
25e
en fait bien différent son procès mais
c'est plus long
l'inflation
musique7 de la bande seul avant fusée de
centaines d'années maintenant on a
baissé comme une figure bon discernement
maintenant
[Musique]
du